[Music]
and today a major legal victory for
former president Donald Trump today a
federal judge agreed to pause the
proceedings in his January 6 case that's
the DC case until the courts render a
decision on Trump's claim that he is
immune from prosecution because he was
president at the time joining us now he
is the host of life liberty and Levin we
call him the great one Mark lvin uh
great one legally let's
analyze well first Sean uh No Labels
party do they understand that the No
Labels party is a
label and secondly he's going to take a
twomon tour of the country guy's been a
governor and Senator he's going to take
a tour what we used to call that a
junket and then he wants the people to
Rally to the No Labels party what do you
stand for well can't we all get along so
that's going to fail but anyway let me
go
on first I want to talk about
impeachment
here and I want to say to the three
guests you had on three great chairman I
think you really need to focus in I have
no opposition to focusing on the
financial fraud and the selling of
public office by the Biden family but it
gets very complicated so that should be
article three of the eventual list of
impeachable offenses because I think
this president's impeachable why because
of what should be article one let me
explain Article 2 Section 3 the United
States Constitution compels a president
that he shall take care that the laws be
Faithfully executed
laws be Faithfully executed the
president of the United States has his
own oath and it's not till after he
takes an oath he puts his hand on the
Bible and the right hand in the air and
he takes that oath that he can become
president of the United States during
his inauguration I will Faithfully
execute the Office of the President of
the United States will the best of my
ability preserve protect and defend the
Constitution of the United States so the
Constitution says you may not like
certain laws Joe Biden but you're going
to enforce them otherwise you're d
destroying separation of powers in the
power of the legislature you can't just
blow off the legislature with executive
orders or directives or something of
that sort now why is that important well
because that's exactly what he's done we
don't need hearings we don't need
depositions we don't need testimony we
don't need text messages we don't need
anything Joe Biden has violated every
single federal immigration law that's on
the books he's doing it every day he's
doing it intentionally the board is wide
open the American people are less safe
terrorists are trying to get in
criminals are getting in toxic drugs are
getting in people are dying people are
being raped they're being sold into sex
slavery now why is all that important
it's important because it's an
impeachable offense I just read you the
two sections of the Constitution where
he's required to uphold the law he is
defying and undermining the law now
let's look at impeachment the framers of
the Constitution impeachment what did
they look at they looked at among other
things 17th and 18th century British
common
law and you look at the impeachment
Clause what is a high crime a high crime
means a president goes out and kills a
whole bunch of people no well what does
it mean high in the legal common
vocabulary of the 17th and 18th
centuries of high crimes this is what
the framers looked at is the activity by
or against those who have special duties
acquired by taking an oath of office
that is not shared with ordinary persons
he has committed a high crime multiple
High Crimes by refusing to enforce our
immigration laws now is that easier to
understand is that more important to the
average American can the average
American get behind an impeachment that
makes it clear on article one that this
man has violated at least two Clauses of
the Constitution he will not uphold the
law he will not secure the border that
is a high crime that is an impeachable
offense you see how simple that is we
don't need subpoenas we don't need
depositions all we need is the video
from the TV cameras the second article
should be the student loans issue
separation of powers president doesn't
have the power to seize the power of the
purse from the House of Representatives
that's another separation of powers
issue the Supreme Court already told him
Joe you don't have the power to do that
with those student loans Joe says
Boop and he tries to find a way around
it and he has spent half a trillion
dollars in funds by not enforcing
student loan payments in violation of
the Federal Constitution separation of
powers that power the purse and
violating an order of the Supreme Court
how simple is that how many hearings do
we need on that and then we can have
your article three in the article three
of the other chairman well this money
went here and Ernie did this and Frank
did that I'm not against it a crime is a
crime but Mr and Mrs America cannot
follow all this Mr and Mrs America can
follow what I call my article one they
can follow article two they can see how
it directly affects them that doesn't
give a pass to what should be article
three and this resolution that they pass
for an inquiry allows for them to take
all these things on so as a special
pleader for the Constitution to make
this simple to get the people around you
will the Republicans in Congress please
at least rethink the order of these
things now number
two there's a motion in front of the
Supreme Court by the special prosecutor
there's nothing special about this guy
he's a disaster he's a hack Jack Smith
is trying to force the Judiciary to
follow his lead to have a quick rump
trial in front of a Democrat jury with a
Democrat judge with four phony charges
one the 1871 Clan law two of them the en
run obstruction law which is being
challenged separately third is a federal
contractor law he's trying to bootstrap
Insurrection and seditious conspiracy
into these four ridiculous charges and
he tells the judge I'm going to argue
that Donald Trump actually the violence
that occurred he let it the attempt to
overthrow but he's not charged with any
of that so what the prosecutor is doing
is outrageous more importantly the Trump
lawyers smartly have said wait a minute
you can't charge an ex-president with
acts he took whether you like them or
not when he was president why because he
has immunity well it doesn't follow him
judge trunkin says he's not a king that
has nothing to do with it if the court
takes this up and rules for the
prosecution that means that lawyers can
sue Joe Biden after he leads the
presidency and indict them and any
ex-president the same thing it would be
a disaster the court shouldn't take it
they should let it follow the process
then they should kill they should kill
what Jack Smith's trying to do I'm done
I hear the music I'm going on a twomon
tour to find out what the people want in
my No Labels party but what but why did
the court take it that's the question I
was surprised it should have gone to the
lower court should have taken it that's
right I agree with you it shouldn't have
and I'm worried about it I am too uh
anyway Mark Levin the great one thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else